[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم وسط معارك في جباليا
ومدينه غزه شمالا وخانيونس جنوبا قاده
عسكريون اسرائيليون يقولون ان هدف تدمير
حماس لم يتحقق وتقديرات استخباراتيه
امريكيه تؤكد ان الحركه ما تزال قادره على
ضرب اسرائيل لاشهر عنده وتجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول
السودان يطالب مجلس الامن بتحمل مسؤوليته
تجاه الدول التي تغذي استمرار الحرب من
خلال تزويدها قوات الدعم السريع بالسلاح
والدعم السياسي والاعلامي من جته اكد حاكم
اقليم دارفور وحده السودان وندد بالذين
استعانوا باياد اجنبيه للوصول الى السلطه
حسب وصفه في تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه
مسؤولو منطقه دونيتسك يقولون ان 25 شخصا
قتلوا واصيب اخرون بعد ان قصفت قوات
اوكرانيه طقه فيما قال الرئيس الاوكراني
انه يتوقع التوقيع على عدد من حزم الدفاع
الغربيه الجديده مع بلاده خلال الاسابيع
المقبله الامين العام للامم المتحده ينتقد
غياب مقعد دائم للقاره الافريقيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي ويؤكد عبر حسابه على منصه
اكس ضروره ان تعكس المؤسسات الدوليه عالم
اليوم وليس عالم ما قبل 80 عاما وفق
تعبيره الى
اللقاء
ه